el presidente de martín vizcarra y su
esposa no fueron voluntarios en los
ensayos clínicos de la vacuna destino
farm así lo afirma en un comunicado la
universidad peruana cayetano heredia
entidad que estuvo a cargo de los
ensayos de la vacuna anti coke el
organismo fue enfático al señalar que
martín vizcarra y su esposa maribel díaz
nunca fueron parte del grupo de 12.000
participantes esto desmiente
públicamente a vizcarra quien trató de
tapar el escándalo afirmando que había
sido voluntario diversos juristas
sostienen que vizcarra hizo uso indebido
de su cargo como presidente de los
peruanos y habría llevado a cabo una
presunta negociación incompatible
buscando beneficiarse como presidente
con la vacunación el ex mandatario
habría incurrido en el delito de cohecho
pasivo- porque habría solicitado un
beneficio a cambio de una gestión a
favor del contrato con el laboratorio
chino la fiscalía puede llevar a la
corte a martín vizcarra y si es hallado
culpable
el exmandatario podría ser sentenciado a
una condena que va entre 5 y 8 años de
cárcel no se descarta que en el proceso
también sean llamados la esposa de
vizcarra el jefe de ensayos de las
vacunas y la ex
ministra de salud pilar más de ti